une immense tristesse vous savez nous
perdons un très grand témoin 10,3 de la
martinique mais aussi un acteur de
l'histoire la martinique et lors de
répéter référent c'est un homme de
conviction il a laissé et un patrimoine
exceptionnel à sont payés à la
martinique
il nous a fourni l'essentiel de la
connaissance de l'histoire et c'est
aussi ça a été un fidèle
c'est un référent dans le sens où on
allait toujours le voir pour avoir un
conseil pour puiser dans dans ses écrits
et nous permettre d'avancer c'est une
lourde perte pour le pays pour la
martinique
est-ce que vous avez un beau souvenir à
partager avec nous ce soir
vous savez il y en a beaucoup et de
répéter un trésor de connaissances mais
il n'hésitait pas si très souvent à nous
engueuler à nous bousculer à nous
reprendre sévèrement et à plusieurs
reprises j'ai eu l'occasion d'avoir des
tête à tête avec lui sur certains points
mais je sortais toujours enrichi parce
qu'il est
il alimentait son analyse c'est un
analyste de l'histoire et il nous
permettait souvent de trouver des
solutions les plus pertinentes possibles
face aux problèmes qui se posaient à
nous il faut obtenir ces autos que la
martinique père un des grands hommes du
pays